Oh
the one who you won
[Music]
woo lee
Wonju Hoengseong Taebaek I'm going to
try some overseas aero
a or s or she was over
order you we were to be
karma, plus a word or something, a
law firm gather a toy
Come out so I can't reproduce, give me a toy
[music]
discover
5 hole be a
international #4 2 or the tang
dog symbol is a Chechen pawn major oil
tei oo Were you gonna talk
here we try to be who you or a terse
[music]  ]
woo hoo
[music]
ah ah
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah top we have to walk now It's short ah ah ah ah ah ah
the
yeah  Uh ipl I know the
outside
[music]
Still,
please grasp it until 222 ceo out over
[music]
So when I stab it, oo oh I’m going to like it
to to 5
pyeong
[music]
Oh
hope of god for he wrote to
out holding the photo and holding his own beer
we be too
ah